[Music]
and superhuman memory news I just need
regular human memory news mmm that's
right you do submitted by love from
Philly cheesesteaks a rare condition
allows a woman to remember everything
she has ever experienced I want that
anymore
no pictures are different you can still
share them with other people yeah but
you know that's good and bad because
there's really great memories it's
really bad there's some really bad ones
that you want to forget cuz what if like
let's say the first great breakup that
you had all still hits you just as hard
when you're your age now that's exactly
what what they say about people to have
this condition that she has that it's
like it sounds awesome but you remember
everything bad - yeah I'm going to show
you guys this video about Tracy I would
hate to be normally she's pretty
impressive I know that's what I'll hang
it up Shelley why don't you why don't
you pull the chair out for me as if you
did something crazy no or if you having
an argument you said this well actually
if I recall I said this you said this
that and you're like I don't mind that
because I want to seek the truth so if I
[ __ ] up tell me I [ __ ] up I'm down
with that
I just don't want people getting pissed
over a [ __ ] that doesn't really matter
here we go I'm able to remember every
day as if it were yesterday
oh my god
[Music]
febrile evans 1990 was the day that
Nelson Mandela was released from prison
what the 16th of October 1978 Pope John
Paul was named Pope November 9th 1989
was the day that the Berlin Wall
officially came down where she must have
killed her history does date that Diana
and Charles go she went so much money in
jeopardy
it wasn't Wednesday Wow that's [ __ ]
nuts they shot this on Instagram where
it's 2010 and think of March 4th it's
it's almost instantaneous it's gone a
DVD is being put in and then set to play
that year on March 4th members from my
office decided to go have an impromptu
after work gathering at the local pub so
now I've just remembered that before I
was able to go to that I also had to go
to a bank and make a credit card payment
because my credit card payment was doing
March 4th and I think I made the minimum
like $85 can see I think you might got
some money $20 to be able to go to the
bar and join my friends that afternoon
so that informations coming in damn she
has to work for the government
she has her song I wish I had this large
portion of information will immediately
hit
and then the rest kind of comes in like
snow almost like a game of Tetris it's
like starting to fall into place yeah
it's incredible if you're an actor or an
actress
killer yeah if you can recall specific
moments that trigger a very specific
emotional response because I think my
actors get the dig yeah and then you
have to get to this girl she just plays
a DVD that's awesome do I wonder if she
could remember she was coming out the
vagina what no you know what's crazy so
looking into this after hearing about
Tracy
I looked into like other people have had
Hassan and those is one woman she
remembers the earliest of her memories
is when she was 12 days old remember is
like her first birthday wearing the
itchy dress and like all these crazy
detailed words like how cute so kids can
feel when shits itchy I remember when I
was younger I remembered a lot of things
from when I was like three yeah yeah the
older if I look at a picture it could
Java memory a little bit you know but
then sometimes too like I heard like
when you look at those things your mind
just tested like filling gaps that
really weren't there they're not
memories they're just kind of filling in
what you think it would be like so
that's the other like confusion - yeah I
feel like what she has it's kind of like
do you guys remember that one movie of
limitless Oh give me that pillow is that
Bradley Cooper yeah I never watched it I
like movies but just watch that yeah but
with that pillow like it gave him access
to his whole brain or whatever so I feel
like she kind of has that a little bit
with the memory that's poking her entire
memory because it seemed like it's also
emotional it's like very factual and I
think that's really cool because now you
have a you could understand your whole
life's journey
pretty well but it doesn't hit her like
you know actually wasn't crying because
she didn't have money or like whatever
she's just all the logical things was
pretty cool well maybe if she remembered
a sad moment she would be
hop into it I'm trying to remember small
thing right now and all the details are
not there with the small thing like I'm
trying to remember like the first ball I
ever had a crush on I could kind of
picture her face but I can't remember
the details right now I can't picture
the face or the name of my first I
remember the second crush I my name is
Rachel his eyes all backlit already
choked it snuck in great what do you
think she now I have no idea I actually
looked her up I think I was in high
school just like when was it Facebook or
my faith I let our college just to see
how my old childhood crushes look like
[Laughter]
if you hit your prime early that's bad
news like you know the girls that are
hot in high school they're busted in
college and if you're hot in second
grade
you're already busted find time in the
fifth grade dad that's generally true
but I did know a couple girls and guys
too that they were like hot since like
elementary school like they were always
like the popular good-looking kid yeah
all the way up until like right now
they're both parents like there's two
people I'm thinking about and I know
good-looking
recently I came across the one Instagram
like damn how do you guys this day like
yo y'all remember uh where were you next
no this job was there but there was
these a couple of people that came up to
us and they yo we're huge fans bah bah
bah blah looking all cool thanks and we
took a picture with them and I was you
know she's like talking about time like
her age and like we still want to travel
like how old are you oh I have a kid
that's like 15 I think what the [ __ ]
that she was like my cousin Amy
cuacamole Asian um yeah and they uh but
they you know they dress very nicely
still does their hair and makeup
whatever whatnot but they just kind of
live life that they have a very young
vibe to them and they were probably like
in there like late 40s that's like car a
fashion illustrator Murray and Bardot
brigade
oh yeah I first interviewed her shows
this town us about her kids and then
all this kids 27 what the 27 yeah it's
crazy I tell her that too I'm like Marie
she's always telling me like all you
kids I'm like what are you talking about
you look like oh my god see I'm doing it
wrong I love her she's awesome reason
awesome I hope I look like this age for
a good long time because I look like
mrs. house 15 yeah
so I look like an old man all the way
there's a hopeful I just stay here so
you guys just go past me just be nice to
me and usually that has a baby on her
hip
you'll be nice to her I'll probably be
nice to the baby I'll probably disclose
hello I can just brainwash this baby
like that's a bad man right whatever
what do you want have the face the
children all like I don't know I have
Vikon brainwash no I'm just like here's
a little baby closure is David always do
exercises his mouth all the time you can
recognize everything that you say we got
do the whisper no but I reckon the whole
memory thing though you know it's a
crazy side effect that I experienced
after having Isaac was the fact that I
lost a lot of my memories especially in
high school it was really crazy so I got
pregnant when I was 17 and then like
years later I saw a lot of people from
high school and they would tell me like
I remember we had this class together
and I'm like remember I took that class
like I remember got so much [ __ ] about
this I told y'all the baby sucks you're
like for some it really truly does and
I'm sorry but it does no crazy it is I
no longer lose hair right now like like
before when I would take a shower like
the drain would have like hair now like
it's I think it's sucking on my life
away that like it's my hair is holding
on stone thick right now all slamming
her had the other day they had a lot of
good
it's really crazy
also lost a sense of time for for like a
couple years I couldn't tell like how
many minutes have gone by if you told me
like it hasn't been a minute or like an
hour I'd be like I'm not sure it was
these little babies they just take
everything from you
yeah some of these ladies that I've seen
friends of mine that I'm like you guys
look great fantastic right when they
have a baby they look like a mommy
Oh mommy yes just like all the nutrients
were picking you have to remain active
so I'm just banking off of just exercise
that's what I'm betting on the Hopi and
pets it up yeah she's good she's sexy 82
do you guys even remember what your
earliest memory was cuz no it was
sitting at this salon because my mom was
working and like um we weren't at home
so I just had to accompany her cuz I
wasn't old enough to go to school and I
just remember a customer of hers had
like this little Bart keychain like Bart
from hoarseness his keychain he was like
on a skateboard and like he'll play with
me with this keychain and I remember
I'll be eating cereal and I think she
would dunk it in my cereal yeah I'll be
laughing I'm like laughing so hard
because like dude this is awesome and my
mom was like all right like it's your
turn to get a haircut and then to do
left and I was like on board like that's
my earliest memory how old are you uh uh
it was before kindergarten so it's like
three four maybe that's my earliest
memory it's hard to say what the
earliest remember I just played I know
like specific things in kindergarten
that happen yeah well I know there's our
leader ones there I just can't remember
as vivid because it's a story I'm told
before when I was playing house in
kindergarten and I smashed that kid in
the face with that pot cause he try to
take my [ __ ] whilst playing house [ __ ]
that kid [ __ ] yeah hey guys how did you
guys like that Jay can use episode well
let us know by liking the video for more
videos click right over here
[Music]
[Music]